The next case continues our discussion of exclusive conditions in this case,
which comes to us from the Kansas Supreme Court.
We deal with an insurance company that refuses to pay a claim because of the
policy holders.
Failure to meet one of the conditions stated in the insurance policy.
The plaintiff in this case is Forrest d Ferguson who ran a drugstore in a small
town in eastern Kansas on the night of March 8th,
1960.
The drugstore was burgled.
The burglar caused some damage to the store and stole some pills,
but the biggest lost with $433 stored in a safe in the drugstore.
The safe had two layers of protection.
The outer door had a combination lock while the inner door opened with the key.
The burglar had somehow managed to open the outer door,
leaving no visible damage,
but he or she had punched out the lock on the inner door.
Mr. Ferguson had taken out a storekeepers burglary and robbery policy from
Phoenix Assurance Company of New York,
which he expected would cover his losses from the burglary.
Instead it,
uh,
it pointed to the section of the policy on safe burglary and claimed that it
could not cover the losses above $50 unless there was visible damages on all of
the safes doors.
Ferguson then sued for the remainder of the money.
We're reading the Kansas Supreme Court's opinion in this case,
which deals with the question of whether a court can compel an insurance company
to reimburse a policy holder if that policy holders loss is excluded by
contractual language,
but that exclusion appears to contravene the contracts purpose.
The trial court in this case had found this question obvious.
A burglary had clearly occurred and money was taken from the safe.
Compensating for this kind of loss was exactly the purpose for which Mr.
Ferguson had bought the insurance in the first place and so it wouldn't allow
the insurance company to get out of pain by using quote an escape clause.
The Kansas Supreme Court takes a somewhat more circuitous route to affirming the
trial court's ruling.
It starts by noting the general rule that ambiguities and insurance contracts
are interpreted against the insurance company that issued them.
This is the great contra proffer.
Endom uh,
standard,
uh,
for insurance interpretation,
Justice Schroeder writing for the majority concedes that even so they cannot
quote give an unnatural meaning to the language unquote of the contract.
This is a fancy way of saying if it's not ambiguous,
you can't hold the ambiguity's against the drafter.
This is where justice prices descent branches off.
He finds that the clause in question is plain,
clear and unambiguous.
Let's take a look at the clause in question.
The contracts definition of safe burglary.
As we can see in order to count as safe burglary,
the money must have been stored in a safe with a combination lock and the safe
must have been completely closed and locked at the time of the burglary.
The burglar must have used force and violence to get into the safe and there
must be visible marks of that force and violence on the exterior of all the
safes.
Doors just as Schroeder makes the distinction between substantive and
evidentiary conditions.
In his analysis of this clause.
He finds that the requirement that the safe be opened with force and violence is
a substantive condition meant to exclude the possibility of an inside job done
simply to collect insurance money.
This requirement's specifies the types of risks that are meant to be insured and
is therefore essential to the insurance company's ability to price it's
insurance policies.
On the other hand,
the requirement that there be visible marks is quote intended to determine the
character of the evidence necessary to show liability unquote,
not to specify the sorts of situations the insurance policy is meant to cover
just just,
just as Schroeder holds that where a rule of evidence is imposed by a provision
in an insurance policy is here.
The assertion of such rule by the insurance carrier beyond the reasonable
requirements necessary to prevent fraudulent claims against it in proof of the
substantive conditions imposed by the policy contravenes the public policy of
this state,
the trial court found that the drug store is safe,
was truly broken into by burglars.
That is,
it wasn't an inside job.
Exactly the sort of thing the clause was meant to protect against to just as
Schroeder,
it goes against public policy to allow the insurance company to use an
evidentiary condition to say that this is not the case,
especially when a court of law has found that it is in fact true.
There are a couple of things worth noting about this decision.
The first is that the court is not finding the condition to be unconscionable or
construing the contract in favor of the insured.
Instead,
it's finding it to be against public policy for insurance companies to use super
restrictive evidentiary rules to avoid acknowledging what has been shown to be
the truth.
Other states often have statutory rules against insurance companies use of
conditions requiring that the condition actually have quote increased the risk
of loss or contributed to the loss under such rules.
That condition in this case would probably not justify denying an insurance
payment.
It's possible though that had the Phoenix assurance company written the contract
differently.
For example,
by clearly labeling this requirement as an exclusion,
it might've prevailed.
This would not have been a ridiculous requirement to impose this kind of
exclusion provision would have incentivized policy holders like Mr. Ferguson to
close and lock the door and spin the combination rather than leaving the door,
the outer door of the safe unlocked as many people do or choosing not to spin
the combination students,
a former high school students might remember from your high school days that if
you don't spin the combination,
uh,
on your locker,
you can sometimes open the locker,
but just moving the uh,
the spinner to the third number instead of having to dial in all three numbers.
Burt Reynolds explained this in his role as a safecracker in the movie breaking
in,
he was able to break into safes more easily because people often fail to spin
the dial after the last time they unlocked the safe.
One way to criticize the opinion then is that the court might have been mistaken
in thinking that the only purpose of the visible marks language was as evidence
of inside jobs.
It might have had an additional purpose to exclude coverage if the insured was
negligent in closing,
locking and spinning.
The combination.
Well,
let's take a look at a quiz.
Hey,
car insurance contract excludes recovery.
If the driver was under the influence of alcohol or any intoxicants that impairs
the driver's ability to drive unquote a driver is drowsy because he took an
antihistamine and hit a tree.
Can he recover?
The court would likely find that this contract is ambiguous and raw and resolve
the meaning against the company.
While anti-histamines do impair a person's ability to function normally and
particularly to drive,
they do not generally fall into the category of drugs we call and toxicants.
Since exceptions to insurance contracts or read narrowly so as to favor the
policyholder,
this driver would be likely to recover.
We have seen the courts tend to construe insurance contracts against insurance
companies and that many states even have statutory rules that disfavor insurance
company's use of conditions to limit their liability.
In this case,
the Kansas Supreme Court found that it contravene public policy to allow an
insurance company to avoid liability by means of an evidentiary policy provision
that went well beyond what was necessary to prove the substantive requirements
for liability.